[Música]
para los artesanos es el grial el logro
de una vida el reconocimiento de un
saber hacer excepcional el título de
mejor obrero de francia
230 profesiones participan en esta
competencia
estos grandes nombres de la cocina
francesa se han reunido para juzgar una
de las especialidades más prestigiosas
la pastelería hay mejores chocolateros
de francia- mejores obreros cocineros de
francia- mejores obreros pasteleros de
francia- y grandes profesionales que
vienen de toda francia
es un placer convocar a un jurado como
este es hermoso es maravilloso y es un
privilegio incluso
en la cocina suena la campana
los 15 candidatos al título supremo
trabajan bajo la atenta mirada de los 15
jurados
todo se detalla todo se anota
y esto ha sucedido durante casi 100 años
los trajes han cambiado pero los
requisitos siguen siendo los mismos el
concurso el mejor obrero de francia
existe desde 1924
su objetivo destacar el trabajo manual y
la artesanía
ya se han coronado nueve mil ganadores
certificación de gran calidad el
concurso del mejor obrero de francia
selección despiadada para dar a este
maestro la oportunidad de mostrar un
gran talento
también hay talento en shock para la
final de la selección de arte floral
este elemento tendrá que ser digno de un
trabajo de orfebrería y alta costura
el mismo tema las mismas flores para
todos y sin embargo ocho creaciones muy
personales ahora mismo es realmente el
último minuto son realmente los últimos
puntos de pegada este es el acabado
extremo la cuarta prueba ha terminado
el trabajo de los candidatos de esta
hora en manos del jurado
tenemos la realización de la pieza
floral la composición de la línea de la
forma de la pieza la elección de las
plantas la adecuación con el tema
incluyente puntos luego la legibilidad
etcétera la escala es precisa para un
título que debe ser honrado durante toda
la vida coherencia del trabajo de la
planta con el tema 10 puntos para mí es
un concurso creo que no hay que tenerlo
muy joven porque es muy difícil de
llevar
en la final del concurso de cantería se
juega en casa
llega el ruido trabaja duro en su obra
maestra cada vez que puede
allí era que estás haciendo exactamente
ahora mismo estoy dando forma a las
hojas acabadas de la marquesina
estoy realmente la coronación de la
columna
el reto del cantero
reproducir idénticamente una columna de
mármol esculpida en el siglo 13 en un
monasterio italiano
la forma es compleja así que no puedes
callar o tendrás que empezar de nuevo
realmente conseguimos el bloque tal y
como está para permitirnos esculpir ese
elemento
el nudo que va de este punto a este otro
las reglas prohíben a llegar terminar
totalmente su columna
tiene que dar los últimos golpes de
cincel delante de un jurado
[Música]
ese día los cinco finalistas deberán
elaborar sus columnas
este es el momento más delicado de la
final
pero más allá de la competencia hay
solidaridad entre los candidatos
vaya
en particular para finalizar el montaje
de las obras maestras si ayudan unos a
otros vemos a los colegas ayudarse entre
sí y esto es realmente un espíritu de
competencia pero también de compañerismo
llega le está colocando el último toque
una columna de casi 350 kilos que ha
ocupado su vida durante meses nueve
meses de trabajo en total son entre
nueve meses de un año de trabajo que se
detiene y luego uno recibe medalla o no
eso es todo
así que al menos hemos tenido el mérito
de llevar el proyecto hasta el final de
hacerlo y de haberlo terminado y ver la
obra finalizada así que es un gran gran
alivio
el jurado decidirá cuál de estas cinco
columnas de primera plana ganará el
título definitivo
los pasteleros también exponen sus
esculturas de azúcar y chocolate
sólo 5 de los 15 candidatos ganarán el
preciado sésamo
pero esta formidable aventura quedará
para cada uno de ellos y para siempre
[Música]
marcada
por el aroma de la excelencia
[Música]